Hey, everyone.
We're going to be taking a look at two actions that are ...
actually costly and people pursue them all the time.
These are our sunk and hidden cost fallacies.
Let's jump into it.
Have you ever forced yourself to sit through a terrible movie ...
just because you paid for the movie ticket?
Or spent hours trying to fix something when starting over ...
would have been faster?
You're not alone, and you may have fallen into ...
one of the two common traps, the sunk cost fallacy or the ...
hidden cost fallacy.
These mental pitfalls affect our personal lives,
our work, and even major corporate ...
and government decisions.
Here we're going to look at how they are different and ...
how you can avoid them.
Let's start with the basics.
Sunk cost is anything you've already spent money,
time, or effort that you can't get back.
The sunk cost fallacy happens when we let those ...
past investments influence our future decisions,
even when doing so makes no rational sense.
In other words, just because you've already ...
spent, it doesn't mean you should ...
keep spending more.
Here, do you want to continue to ...
watching that movie that you don't like,
or do you want to do something else?
We should ignore what we've already spent.
Now contrast that with a hidden cost.
Hidden cost are not about the past.
They're about the cost we don't immediately notice or measure.
And when we fall into the hidden cost fallacy,
we ignore those irrelevant costs in our decisions.
So here they may be emotional stress,
time loss, mental fatigue,
or missed opportunities.
They sneak up on us and often turn a seemingly cheap ...
decision into an expensive one.
In the long run, let's think about the coffee ...
shop that wants to add alcohol beverages to the menu.
What takes place here?
Well, if we have a bunch of people ...
who work in our coffee shop and they're under the age of ...
21, then we might run into an ...
issue with a legal issue in which we have to hire more ...
people who are of legal age that can serve and pour the ...
alcoholic beverages.
So that's an additional cost that we did not consider initially.
Now, let's think about the common ...
confusion that arises between the two.
Here's where it gets tricky.
People often mix up these.
Let's take an example.
You've been on hold with customer service for three ...
hours. That's time.
It's a sunk cost.  It's gone.
You're never going to get it back.
But now you're wondering, do I keep waiting?
That's where the hidden cost comes in.
The cost of waiting longer, maybe another hour, maybe two.
It's hidden to us, it's not just your time,
but your energy, your mood.
Maybe even missing a meeting or dinner.
People often stay in these situations because they don't ...
want to waste what they've already spent.
But the smarter move is to cut your losses and protect ...
your future time and resources.
The rule is simple.
Don't throw good time or money after bad.
Let's turn to some real world applications.
First, let's look at the sunk cost ...
fallacy in the Concorde jet.
Here, the Concorde supersonic jet ...
was built by the British and French governments.
It was an ambitious and expensive project.
But even after it was clear the jet would never be profitable,
they kept pouring money into it. Why?
Because it already spent billions.
That's the textbook sunk cost fallacy.
Continuing a failing investment just because ...
you've already invested heavily.
If they had asked what's the best use of our money going ...
forward, they likely would have ...
canceled it sooner.
The Hidden Cost Fallacy Here,
we're going to look at cheap airfare.
You see a flight for $200 looks like a great deal, right?
But here's the catch.
12 hour layover in the middle of the night,
stuck in the airport, running on no sleep,
wasting your time and energy.
And when you finally arrive, you're exhausted,
behind schedule, and your productivity for the day is shot.
Sure, the ticket was cheap.
But the hidden cost lost time, lost energy, lost comfort.
When you only look at a price tag,
you miss the full cost of your choices.
So what's our lesson?
When making decisions, always look forward, not backward.
The money, time and effort you've already spent is gone.
That's the sunk cost.
Don't let it trap you into continuing something that no ...
longer serves you.
And don't forget to look for the hidden costs,
those sneaky consequences that don't show up in the fine ...
print but hit your wallet.
Your time and your well being.
Later on, being aware of both of these ...
fallacies can help you make smarter,
more rational choices.
Whether you're managing a budget or running a ...
business, or just deciding how to spend ...
your weekend, make decisions based on ...
what's still possible, not what's already lost.
Hope you've enjoyed it.  We'll catch you in our next one.